>>> HELLO, EVERYBODY.
WELCOME TO "THE TOTAL SOCCER
SHOW."
TODAY WE'RE BREAKING DOWN THE
WORLD CUP DRAW LIVE.
THE USA IS IN IT, WHICH IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING FOR
EVERYONE INVOLVED TO BREAK DOWN
THAT DRAW, I'M JOINED BY TWO
WONDERFUL GENTLEMEN -- ONE
GENTLEMAN AND ONE JOE LOWERY.
GRAHAM, ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITH
BEING A GENTLEMAN?
>> YEYEAH, I GUESS.
I DON'T THINK I'VE BEEN
DESCBED AS A GENTLEMAN, IDON'T
HAS BEEN DESCRIBED AS A
GENTLEMAN BEFORE, BUT I'LL TAKE
IT, GREAT.
>> JOE, THAT MAKES YOU THE BAD
BOY OUTSIDER.
TOTALLY FITTING FOR YOU.
>> I'M ALL ABOUT THAT BAD BOY
VIBE.
PERFECT CASTING.
GREAT JOB.
>> RYAN BAILEY IS NOT WITH US
TODAY, BUT THE THREE OF US WILL
BREAK DOWN THE DRAW.
BOTH OF YOU ARE IN POT "A" FOR
BEING MY HEART.
WE HAVE EIGHT TEAMS, ALL DECIDED
BY THE COEFFICIENT RANKING,
QATAR IS GOING RIGHT INTO GROUP
"A."
WE GO TO ONE, EACH TEAM GETS
ASSIGNED T TO A POT, THE SAME
THING HAPPENS WITH TWO, THREE
AND FOUR.
ONCE WE HAVE ALL OF OUR GRPS,
WE'LL KNOW WHICH IS THE GROUP OF
DEATH AND WHICH THE UNITED
STATES IS GOING TO WIN.
THE ONLY OTHER RULES WOULD BE,
EVERY GROUP WILL HAVE AT LEAST
ONE EUPEAN TEAM, FIVE GROUPS
WILL HAVE TWO EUROPEAN TEAMS.
GRAHAM, CAN YOU TAKE US THROUGH
POT ONE, PLEASE?
>> YEAH.
SURE.
POT ONE, AS YOU SAY, SORTED BY
RANKINGS.
YOU HAVE QATAR IN THERE AS THE
ST NATION, JUST TO SHAKE
THINGS UP A LITTLE BIT, SO YOU
HAVE BRAZIL, THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
NATION IN MEN'S WORLD CUP,
BELGIUM, YOU HAVE FRANCE, OF
COURSE THE DEFENDING CHAMPIONS
FROM 2018, YOU HAVE ARGENTINA,
YOU HAVE ENGLAND, SPAIN, AND
PORTUGAL AS WELL.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE P ONE THERE.
WE'LL BE TALKING MORE ABOUT
THOSE TEAMS AS THEY'RE ASSIGNED.
JOE LOWERY, TAKE US THROUGH POT
TWO?
>> I WILL, IN ONE SECOND.
TAYLOR, I CAN'T BELIEVE WE
HAVEN'T ARESS THE GRAHAM
B
CUTOUT OF RYAN BAILEY ON THE
SCREEN.
>> SO SHY.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT HE' GOT TO
SAY.
OH.
CHARLOTTE WILL WIN AN MLS CUP.
HE'S AIN ME WHERE THE NEAREST
HARD ROCK CAFE IS.
LITTLE RYAN BAILEY HE.
>> HOW DID YOU MAKE THAT?
HOW DID YOU GET THE MOST PERFECT
FACE?
>> I MEAN, IT WASN'T
DIFFICULT -- THIS IS HIS GENERAL
EXPRESSION.
HIS RESTING RYAN FACE.
>> MY GOSH.
>> GO ENGLAND.
>> I'M SO HAPPY RIGHT NOW.
>> THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
AMAZING.
THANK YOU, GRAHAM.
GLAD YOU'RE HERE WITH US.
POT TWO.
THE NETHERLANDS ARE IN POT TWO
ALONG WITH GERMANY, DENMARK,
SWITZERLAND, CROATIA, URUGUAY,
THE UNITED STATES AND MEXICO.
SO THOSE ARE YOUR EIGHT TEAMS
THAT ARE RIGHT AFTER THE TOP POT
IN TERMS OF THE FIFA RANKINGS.
>> USA AHEAD OF NETHERLANDS AND
GERMANY.
GRAHAM, HOW ABOUT POT THREE?
>> POT THREE WE HAVE SENEGAL,
RECENTLY WON AFCON, IRAN, JAPA
WE HAVE MOROCCO, SERBIA, POLAND
WHO CAME THROUGH THE PLAYOFFS,
SOUTH KOREA AND FINALLY CANADA.
OUR TAB TOPPERS IN CONCACAF
AND WELL DONE TO CANADA, THEIR
FIRST APPEARANCE AT A WORLD CUP
SINCE 1986.
>> GRAHAM, YOU HAD A 15-MINUTE
PRESENTATION ABOUT ALL OF THE
HISTORICAL CONNECTIONS BETWEEN
THE COUNTRIES IN POT THREE AND
HOW THEY'RE ALL GOING TO PLAY
OUT?
YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
JUST A CORRECTION, CANADA, IN MY
NOTES, I INCORRECTLY HAVE THEM
IN POT THREE, THEY'RE ACTUALLY
IN POT FOUR.
TUNISIA IS IN THEIR PLACE IN POT
THREE.
>> I BELIEVE, NUMBER ONE, THAT
WAS A TROLL JOB, BUT BECAUSE YOU
WERE TROLLING CANADA, I'M TAKING
AWAY THE 15-MINUTE PRESENTATION.
>> I LIKE CANADA.
>> JOE, POT FOUR?
>> YOU GOT .
CANADA ARE IN POT FOUR.
THEY WE STUCK THERE AFTER THEY
COULDN'T GET A RESULT.
THE RESULT THEY NEEDED ON THE
LAST DAY OF CONCACAF WORLD CUP
QUALIFYING.
CANADA, CAMEROON, ECUADOR, SAUDI
ARABIA, GHANA AND SOME OF THE
PLAYOFFS HERE.
THESE ARE THE TEAMS THAT HE
YET TO BE DECED AS TO WHETHER
THEY'LL BE IN THE WORLD CUP OR
NOT.
SCOTLAND, UKRAINE, WALES, WALES
IS THROUGH, SCOTLAND STILL HAS
THEIR GAME PENDING VERSUS
UKRAINE.
WE'RE NOT SURE WHEN THAT WILL
TAKE PLACE.
ONE OF THOSE THREE TEAMS WILL BE
IN POT FOUR ALONG WITHUSTRALIA
OR THE UAE OR PERU.
THERE'S ACTION THERE TO BE
PLAYED.
THE FINAL SPOT BETWEEN THE
FOURTH PLACE TEAM IN CONCACAF
AND THE WINNER OF OCEANA, COSTA
RICA VERSUS NEW ZEALAND.
COSTA RICA HEAVY FAVORITES
THERE.
>> AS WE WAIT FOR FIFA TO TAKAK
ITS JOLLY OLD-TIME TO GET THE
PICKS STARTED, LET'S GO TO THE
PLAYOFFS.
GRAHAM, I WANTED TO ASK YOU,E
TALKED ABOUT HOW YOU'RE SORT OF
FEELING ABOUT THE SITUATION,
WAITING FOR THE SCOTLAND/UKRAINE
GAME, THEN IDEALLY ADVANCING TO
WALES, BUT BEFORE EVERYTHING
HAPPENED, WHEN THE DRAW FIRST
WAS ANNOUNCED, WHEN YOU KNEW YOU
WOULD BE PLAYING UKRAINE AND
THEN POTENTIALLY WALES, HOW DID
YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT DRAW?
HOW DID YOU FEEL ABOUT GOI UP
AGAINST UKRAINE BEFORE THE
INVASION BY RUSSIA?
>> SO, IT WAS ACTUALLY ONE OF
THE MORE FAVORABLE DRAWS.
SCOTLAND, AMAZINGLY, I DON'T
KNOW HOW IT HAPPENED, WE WERE
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE SEEDED TEAMS
FOR THE PLAYOFFS ALONG WITH THE
LIKES OF PORTUGAL AND ITALY AND
A LOT OFHE GOOD AMS.
WE WER UP THERE WITH THEM AS
ONEE OF THE SEEDS, WE GOT
UKRAINE, WHICH WE WERE MEANT TO
GET AS A FAVORABLY MORE DRAW
FROM THAT.
UKRAINE FACING A WHOLE LOT O OF
STUFF AT THE MOMENT WHICH
TRANENDS SOCCER, I'M SURE
THEIR NATIONAL TEAM ARE NOT EVEN
THINKING ABOUT T THAT GAM AT TH
MOMENT.
IN TERMS OF THEIR SOCCER TEAM, I
THINK THAT'S AN EVEN BATTLE
BETWEEN UKRAINE AND SCOTLAND,
BUT I WOULD FANCY THEIR CHANCES
AT HOME.
WALES INHE FINAL, I THINK
WE'RE A BETTER TEAM AS A WHOLE
THAN WALES, BUT THEY GOT THAT
RTAIN WINGER WHO CAN PRODUCE
SOMETHING.
HE MAKES ME NERVOUS.
I HOPE WE GET TO THAT  GA.
AT THE MOMENT IT FEELS A LITTLE
BIT IRRELEVANT AT THE MOMENT.
THERE'S A STRANGE FEELING
WATCHING SCOTLAND TECHNICALLY
BEING IN THE DRAW TODAY A AND N
KNOWING WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
UKRAINE'S PATH OR WALES' PATH TO
THIS TOURNAMENT.
>> I IMAGINE IT'S VERY MUCH NOT
FUN.
THE FUN THING, I GUESS FOR ME
AND JOE, WOULD BE IF WE DO END
UP POTENTIALLY GETTING THE
INTO THE USA'S GROUP.F SERIES
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS ON THEHOW
THIS WEEK.
IT WOULD BE VERY FUN TO GET EVEN
AN ENGLAND/USA/SCOTLAND GROUOUP.
I THINK THAT MIGHT ALSO TEAR US
APART.
I THINK PLENTY OF PEOPLE POINT
OUT THERE'S A POSSIBILITY OR A
NOT LIKELIHOOD BUT A STRONG
PERCENTAGE CHANCE THAT THE
UNITED STATES DOES END UP IN A
GROUP WITH THE WINNER OF THAT
SCOTLAND/WALES/UKRAINE PLAYOFF.
IF YOU HAD TO PLAY THE UNITED
STATES, BASED SOLELY ON THE LAST
TWO GAMES YOU SAW FROM THEM
VERSUS PANAMA AND COSTA RICA,
HOW ARE YOU FEELING ABOUT THAT
ONE?
>> OKAY WITH THE COSTA RICA
GAME, BUT NOT SO OKAY WITH THE
PAMA GAME.
THERE SEEMED TO BE QUITE A
DIFFERENCE IN PERFORMANCE
LEVELS.
TO BE HONEST, AND NOT TO THROW
SHADE AT THE U.S. OR CONCACAF,
OUT OF THE POT TWO TEAMS THAT
SCOTLAND GET THROU TO THE
TOURNAMENT ITSELF, THE USA AND
MEXICO PROBABLY WOULD BE THE TWO
TEAMS THAT I PERSONALLY WOULD
PICK OUT.
I WOULD LIKE THAT, AN AMERICAN
DRAW IN OUR GROUP VERSUS
SCOTLAND FOR TSS REASONS.
I DO THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT
GERMANY, NETHERLANDS, DENMARK
O WE HAD IN THE QUALIFICATION
GROUP, WE DIDN'T BEAT DENMARK,
BUT THEY'RE A VERY, VERY GOOD
TEAM.
THE U.S. FEELS LIKE A WORK IN
PROGRESS.
MEXICO, EVEN THOUGH THEY
FINISHED THE QUALIFICATION
CAMPAIGN RELATIVELY WELL,
THERE'S A BIT OF DISGRUNTLEMENT
UNDER MARTINO.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW THEY'RE
PLAYING.
SO THE U.S. AND MEXICO FOR ME,
AGAIN, NOT THROWING SHADE, BUT
THEY BE SLIGHTLY WEAKER TEAMS.
I WAS THINKING BEFORE LOOKI AT
THE POTS AND BEFORE THE DRAW,
THERE'S NOT A LOT BETWEEN A LOT
OF THE POTS.
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THEY CHANGED
THIS RECENTLY IN TERMS OF HOW
THEY'RE DOING THE POT.
IT USED TO BE DON BY REGION.
NOW IT'S BY RANKING.
EVEN WITH RANKINGS, YOU HAVE
GERMANY AND NETHERLANDS IN POT
TWO.
THEY COULD EASILY BEAT POT ONE
TEAMS.
SENEGAL AND SERBIA IN POT THREE.
CAMEROON, ECUADOR AND GHANA IN
POT FOUR.
THESE ARE HIGH-QUALITY TEAMS.
I THINK IT'S EVEN ACROSS THE
SPLIT WITH THE POTS.
>> JOE, WE'RE GETTING O HOSTS
OUT ON THE STAGE ONE BY ONE.
I WOULD SAY VERY SLOWLY, WHICH
GIVES US SOME TIME TO TAKE SOME
QUESTIONS FROM TWITTER.
ONE COM TO US FROM TONY3FLASH.
MEXICO AND U.S. WILL NOT ADVANCE
OUT OF THE FIRST ROUND.
DISAGREE.
I NEED A THIRD TEAM TO ROOT FOR,
MAYBE CANADA?
>> I GENERALLY TAKE THE CONCACAF
O
OVERALL APPROACH.
I WROTE THIS FOR THE ATHLETIC A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO, THEY'RE A
LIKABLE AM FILLED WITH
IMPRESSIVE PLAYERS.
ALFONSO DAVIS IS THEIR TALISMAN.
JONATHAN DAVID WHO PLAYS FOR
LILLE AND PROBABLY WILL BE
MOVING THIS SUMMER.
THEY HAVE A NICE NUMBER 6 WHO
JUST MOVED TO PORTO IN THE
WINTER WINDOW ON LOAN.
THERE'S A TON OF TALENT HERE.
MLS TIE-INS AS WELL.
CANADA ARE A GOOD TEAM BUILT
WIWITH GOOD PLAYERS.
I THINK THE STYLE THEY PLAY,
WHICH IS GENERALLY -- THIS IS A
SIMPLIFIED WAY TO PHRASE IT,
THEY'RE TRYING TO FRUSTRATE.
THEY'RE TRYING T TO MAKE YOU HI
AND OVER AGAIN, WIN THE BALL AND
ATTACK QUICKLY AFTER THEY WIN IT
THROUGH THEIR EXTREMELY TALENTED
PLAYERS.
BEUCHANAN ANOTHER ONE I DIDN'T
MENTION.
IF YOU'R LOOKING FOR TEAM TO
ROOT FOR,R, IF YOU DON'T THINK E
U.S. AND MEXICO WILL DO WELL,
CANADA ARE HIGH ON THAT LIST.
>> STICKING WITH OUR
SPECIFICALLY U.S. INTERESTS FOR
A MOMENT, MIGHTYMOUSE1371 ASKS
HOW BAD WILL BE THE U.S. BE
SCREWED?
I MIGHT EVEN DISAGREE WITH THAT
ONE.
THESE POT ARE PRETTY BALANCED.
NOT AN OBVIOUS ONE IN MY MIND
FOFORROUP OF DEATH.
DO YOU HAVE ANY CONCERNS FOR THE
UNITED STATES WITH THIS DRAW?
>> IT'S TOO EARLY TO TOELL.
THERE'S A CHANCE THAT THE U.S.
GETS BRUTAL GROUP.
YOU COULD END UP WITH ONE OF THE
EUROPEAN TEAMS IN POT ONE, WHICH
MEANS YOU COU STILL HAVE
ANOTHER EUROPEAN TEAM LATER.
YOU COULD END UP WITH A TEAM
LIKE ECUADOR IN THE LAST POT OR
SENEGAL WHO ARE THE BEST TEAM IN
POT THREE.
THERE'S A CHANCE THAT THE U.S.
GETS A BRUTAL DR, BUT THAT'S
TRUE FOR MOST TEAMS.
TH ONE THING THAT WE KNOW ABOUT
THIS U.S. TEAM, THEY WON'T BE
ABLE TO DRAW CANADAROM POT
UR, WHICH IS A HUGE THING FOR
THEM.
YOU CAN'T DRAW UNLESS YOU'RE
UEFA ANOTHER TEAM FROM THIS
CONFEDERATION.
THAT'S A GOOD THING FOR THE
U., I DID A WHOLE SPIEL ON
CANADA AND HOW THEY COULD MAKE A
RUN IN THIS COMPETITION.
>> BECAUSE THE UNITED STATES
FOUND ITS WAY INTO POT TWO, I
THINK THEY HAVE NOT
HISTORICALLY, IF THEY WERE IN
POT THREE OR FOUR, THEN THERE'S
THAT POSSIBILITY THAT YOU GET
BRAZIL AND GERMANY OUT OF POT
ONE AND POT TWO, THAT WOULD BE A
ROUGH DRAW.
SO THEY AVOID THEHE NETHERLANDS
GERMANY, CROATIA, URUGUAY,
SWITZERLAND HAVING HANDED THE
U.S. A DEFEAT PREVIOUSLY.
GRAHAM, FROM A U.S. PERSPECTIVE,
IS THERE A TEA IN POT ONE YOU
SHOULD THEY SHOULD MOST WANTING
TO AVOID?
I ASSUME THE ANSWER IS BRAZIL.
>> YES.
BRAZIL LOOK VERY, VERY STRONG.
THEY WENT THROUGH QUALIFYING
UNBEATEN.
THEY HAD THAT STRANGEAME
AGAINST ARGENTINA BEING
POSTPONED DUE TO PLAYERS BEING
DRAGGEDFF THE PITCH DURING THE
COVID PANDEMIC.
THAT WAS A WEIRD MATCH.
SO FAR THEY HAVE GONE THROUGH
THAT CAMPAIGN UNBEATEN.
THE MANAGER HAS DONE A VERY GOOD
JOB OF ADDING STRUCTURE TO A
TEAM STACKED WITH OPTIONS.
I THINK ONLY FRANCE, YOU WOULD
SAY, HAVE THE DEPTH THAT BRAZIL
HAVE.
NEYMAR, ANTHONY OF AJAX FAME,
FABINHO, COUTINHO, THEY HAVE
PLAYERS THROUGUGHOUTHAT TEAM.
THIAGO SILVA, DANILO, AIL LESS
SA
ALESSANDRO, THEY HAVE SO MANY
OPTIONS.
IN THE PAST, BRAZIL ALWAYS HAD
GOOD SQUADS.
THEY HAD A GOOD SQUAD IN 2018,
BUT IT FELT LIKE MAYBE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THE STRUCTURE TO
COMPETE OR AT LEAST COMPETE AT
THEIR BEST IN KNOCKOUT FOOTBALL
OR KNOCKOUT FORMATS.
IT FEELS LIKE THEY HAVE THAT
STRUCTURE.
THE MANAGER HAS GOTTEN EVERYBODY
TO BUY INTO THAT STRUCTURE.
IN THE PAST, DONDA TRIED TO DO
IT AND FACED PUSHBACK FROM FANS.
I THINK BRAZIL HAVE HAD ENOUGH
FAILURES IN A ROW SINCE 2002,
THAT'S THE LAST TIME THEY WON
THE WORLD CUP, THEY HAD ENOUGH
FAILURES IN SUCCESSION TO GET
FANS TO BUY IN TO KNOW THEY NEED
MORE THAN FLARE.
>> JOEING JOE, BRAZIL THE TEAM
WOULD MOST LIKIKEO AVOID?
>> ARGENTINA AS WELL.
BOTH OF THOSE SOUTH AMERICAN
GIANTS ARE CERTAINLY TEAMS THAT
YOU WANT TO AVOID.
THAT GOES FOR A LOT OF TEAMS IN
THAT POT.
QATAR ISHE TEAM YOU WANT TO BE
PAIRED WITH IN THAT FIRST GROUP.
THEY ARE THE WEAKEST TEAM.
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THEY'RE A BAD
TEAM.
MAYBE W WE'LL TALK MORE ABOUT TM
AS THEY GET GOING IN THIS DRAW.
A LOT OF TALENT THERE UNDER
FELIX SANCHEZ, THEY PLAY SOME
GOOD SOCCER AS THE U.S. SAW IN
THE GOLD CUP THIS PAST SUMMER.
ARGENTINA SCARES ME BECAUSE OF A
LITTLE MAN NAMED LIONEL MESSI.
I DON'T WANT TO REDUCE ANY TEAM
TO JUST ONE PLAYER, BUT YOU
THINK ABOUT TEAMS WITH ONE
DOMINANT NAME.
POLAND WITH ROBERT LEWANDOWSKI..
MESSI IN ARGENTINA.
THESE ARE PLAYERSHAT CAN SINK
YOU.
IN A ONE-OFFTOURNAMENT, WHERE
LUCK IS A HUGE FACTOR.
TAYLOR, YOU AND I TALKED ABOUT
THE NATIONAL TEAM A HOW
THEY'RE PLAYING TACTICALLY.
I LOVE THAT STUFF, BUT SOMETIMES
TOURNAMENT PLAY, THAT GOES
OUT THE WINDOW.
IT'S A GREAT EQUALIZER.
THAT'S THE EQUALIZER.
TOURNAMENT SOCCER IS A GIANT
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THE WORLD CUP
SO MUCH FUN.
YOU COULD SEE FRANCE GET KNOCKED
OUT IN THE EUROS.
YOU CAN SEE SPAIN GO OUT.
SO MANY DIFFERENT THINGS CAN
HAPPEN.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE BEST PLAYER
WHO HAS EVER PLAYED THIS SILLY
GAME ON YOUR TEAM, IN LIONEL
MESSI, YOU SCARE ME AND ME ME
WANT TO RUN FOR THE HILLS.
ARGENTINA CERTAINLY -- I THINK
IN TERMS OF TEAMS I WOU MOST
LIKE TO SEE END UP IN THE U.S.
GROUP FROM POT ONONE, QATAR IS R
AND AWAY THE TEAM THAT WOULD BE
THE WEAKEST ANDHE BES FOR THE
U.S.
PORTUGAL PROBABLY THE NEXT ONE.
I DON'THINK THEY'RE ALL THAT
EXCEPTIONAL TO WATCH UNDER
FERNANDO SANTOS, NOT THAT
EXPANSIVE AND EXCITING AND THEY
PLAY LESS THAN THE SUM OF THEIR
PARTS.
AGAIN, CRISTIANO RONALDO, BRUNO
FERNANDES, BERNARDO SILVA.
E LIST GOES ON AND ON.
BECAUSE OF HOW THEY PLAY AND
BECAUSE OF HOW I DO THINK SANTOS
HANDICAPS THIS TEAM, THAT COULD
BE DECENT DRAW FOR THE U.S. AS
WELL.
>> JOE, YOU MENTIONED EXPERIENCE
TH
THERE, TOURNAMENT EXPERIENCE
THERE, WH THE U.S. THAT'S
GOING TO BE AN INTERESTING THING
FOR THEM.
SPEAKING AS A SCOTLAND FAN, WE
GOT TO THE EUROS AFTER A LONG
WAIT, WE HAD A YOUNG TEAM, WHEN
WE GOT TO THE EOS IT BECAME
CLEAR THAT WE LACKED A WHOLE
BUNCH OF EXPERIENCE.
A LOT HAS BEEN MADE ABOUT THE
AGE, THE YOUTH OF THIS U.S.
SIDE..
I WONDER IF MAYBE THAT WILL BE
SOMETHING THAT COUNTS AGAINST
THEM WHEN THE TOURNAMENT
ACTUALLY GETS STARTED.
HAVING SAID THAT, THERE'S A LOT
OF PLARS IN THAT TEAM WHO ARE
PLAYING AT A HIGH LEVEL, BIG
CLUBS.
MAYBE NOT SO MUCH.
I GUESS WE'LL FIND OUT.
>> IT'S NOTOT EVEN JUST THE
PLAYERS FOR THE U.S., LET'S NOT
FORGET THE MANAGER IS STILL
RELATIVELY NEW.
IT'S BEEN YEARS NOW, BUTE'S
STILL RELATIVELY NEW TO
INTERNRNATIONAL MANAGEMENT.
NEVER MANAGED AT A WORLD CUP
BEFORE.
WE SAW SOME OF THAT NAIVETE AT
THE START OF THE WORLD CUP
QUALIFYING CAMPAIGN WITH TYLER
ADAMS SAYING WE WANT THIS TO BE
A NINE-POINT WINDOW.
HE WAS JUSTIFIED TO SAY THAT.
THAT SHOULD BE THE GOAL OF ANY
TEAM TO WIN EVERY SINGLE GAME IN
FRONT OF THEM.
WE COULD SEE SOME OF THAT
NAIVETE FROM THE TEAM.
I THINK WORLD CUP QUALIFYING AND
THIS EXPANDED WORLD CUP
QUALIFYING CAMPAIGN TAKES SOME
OF THAT NAIVETE AWAY.
AND HAS BEEN THROUGH A WEIRD AND
CHALLENGING THREE-WINDOW WORLD
CUP QUALIFYING CAMPAIGN.
I THINK THAT WILL HELP.
BUT THAT'S A STORY LINE, THE
INEXPERIENCE OF THIS TEAM AS
THEY HEAD INTO THE WORLD CUP.
>> IN THEMEANTITIME, WE HAVE
STSTARTED T DRAW.
WE HAVE GOT QATAR DRAWN INTO
GROUP ONE.
POSITION ONE.
SO THEY'RE IN A1.
CONGRATULATIONS TO QATAR.
WH KNEW THAT WASAS HAPPENING?
WE HAD ENGLAND DRAW UP NEXT.
WE'LL SEE WHERE THEY END UP.
WE'VE GOT ENGLAND IN GROUP "B."
RYAN BAILEY NOT HERE WITH US TO
DISCUSS HOW STRONG ENGLAND COULD
POTENTIALLY .
THEY'VE BEEN BUILDING TOURNAMENT
ON TOURNAMENT.
DO YOU EXPECT THIS OTO BE THE OE
WHERE THEY MAKE THE FINAL AGAIN
AND THEY DON'T WIN?
>> RYAN BAILEY IS SAYING DIEGO
MARADONA IS A VILLAIN, '96 WAS
THE BEST WORLD CUP WIN OF ALL
TIME.
ENGLAND ARE GOING OUT IN THE
GROUP STAGE.
ONE OF THOSE THINGS IS CERTAINLY
TRUE.
TO BE SERIOUS, THERE IS A SEN
THAT ENGLAND HAVE BEEN BUILDING
TOWARDS THIS TOURNAMENT FOR A
WHILE.
THEY MADE THE SEMIFINALS IN
2018.
IN THE EUROS THEY MAKE THE FINAL
AS WELL.
I ALWAYS THINK WITH ENGLAND,
PART OF THE BATTLE IS JUST
GETTING EVERYONE PULLING INTO
ONE DIRECTION.
THEY HAD NATIONAL TEAM MANNERS
WHO HAVE NOT BEEN POPULAR WITH
PLPLAYERS, WH FANS.
GARETH SOUTHGATE IS POPULAR.
HE'S DONE A GREATAT JOB OF GETTG
THOSE PLAYERS ON THE SAME PAGE.
HE SPEAKS VERY WELL.
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIM AS A
TACTICIAN.
AT THE EUROS THEY WERE TOO
COMPACT AND CONSERVATIVE
CONSIDERING THE CREATIVE TALENT
THEY HAVE.
THAT WILL BE A STORY LINE FOR
THIS TOURNAMENT, CAN THEY
LIBERATE SOME OF THAT ATTACKING
TALENT?
DO THEY NEED TO PLAY DECLAN RICE
AND CALVKALVIN PHILLIPS AS A
MIDFIELD ANCHOR?
CAN THEY FREE UP TO PHIL FODEN
OR MASON MOUNT FURTHER UP THE
PITCH.
IN TERMS OF THE TALENT ENGLAND
GOT, YOU CAN'T DOUBT IT.
HARRY KANE, STERLING, FODEN,
MOUNT, TOP QUALITY PLAYERS.
EVERY RIGHT BACK IN THE WORLD
PLAYS FOR ENGLAND AT THE MOMENT.
>> YES, A HIGH QUALITY TEAM WITH
A GOOD TRACK RECORD WHO SHOULD
BE LOOKIKINGNGO MAKE A DEEP RUNT
THIS TOURNAMENT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL DO SOME CATCHING UP HERE.
ENGLAND IN GROUP "B."
WE JUST HAD FRANCE PLACED INTO
GROUP "D."
FOR PEOPLE WATCHIN AT HOME OR
WATCHING THE DRAW LIVE, YOU
MIGHT SEE YOU'RE GETTING THE
COUNTRIES DRAWN THEN T
SECONDARY DRAW.
YOU HAVE THE RED BALL, BECAUSE
ALL OF THESE TOP SEEDS WILL GET
THAT FIRST  SITION.
THTHEN AFTERTHAT, IT'S A BIT
RANDOM AS I UNDERSTAND IT.
WE KNOW HAVE SPAIN DRAWN INTO
ANYHOUGHTS ON ARGENTINA BEING
ON A STRONG RUN OF FORM?
>> YES.
SO THEY'RE ON A 30-GAME UNBEATEN
RUN AT THE MOMENT, ARGENTINA,
WHICH IS THE LONGEST
INTERNATIONAL SOCCER RIGHT NOW
AFTER ITALYY IMPLODED FOLLOWING
EIR 37-GAME RUN.
AND THEY ARE NOT AT THIS
TOURNAMENT AFTER BEING BEATEN IN
THE PLAYOFFS.
ARGENTINA LOOKS STRONGER FOR
THIS TOURNAMENT THAN THEY HAVE
FOR A WHILE.
CERTAINLY SINCE 2014 WHEN THEY
MADE THE FINAL.
ACTUALLY, IN TERMS OF THEIR
INDIVIDUAL QUALITY AND THEIR
QUALIFICATION CAMPAIGN, I WOULD
SAY THEY'RE EVEN STRONGER THAN
THEY WERE IN 2014.
OF COURSE WE HAVE TO MENTION
LIONEL MESSI, POTENTIALLY THE
BEST PLAYER IN THE WORLD RIGHT
NOW.
THE BEST PLAYER IN THE LAST 10
15 YEARS, STILL A BIG FIGURE FOR
THISTEAM.
WHAT SCALONI HAS DONE IS FIND
HIM SUPPORT.
IT'S NOT ALL ON FERNANDEZ, LO
CELSO, THEY PROVIDE SUPPORT WITH
DIMITR
DI MARIA UP THERE.
THEY HAD THE LIMELIGHT STOLEN BY
BRAZIL, BUT THEY'VE BEEN SOLID
AND VERY IMPRESSIVE BY FINISHING
A COMFORTABLE SECOND IN THAT
TABLE.
>> WE'VE GOT SPAIN IN GROUP "E."
GROUP "F" HAS BELGIUM.
GROUP "G" HAS BRAZIL.
THAT WILL MEAN PORTUGAL GOES
INTO GROUP "H."
THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED YET, AS I
UNDERSTAND THE DRAW.
PORTUGAL INTO GROUP "H."
JOE, WHERE ARE YOU HOPING THE
UNITED STAS IS ENDING UP IF WE
HAVE QATAR IN "A," ENGLAND "B,"
ARGENTINA "C," FRANCE "D," SPAIN
"E," BELGIUM F, BRAZIL G,
PORTUGAL "H."
>> GROUP "A," THAT'S WHERE YOU
WANT T TO BE.
I WANT TO PAUSE ON QATAR.
THEY'RE FAR AND AWAY THE TEAM
YOU WANT TO BE PLACED WITH
BECAUSE OF THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THEM AND THE ACTUAL TOP
SEVEN TEAMS IN THEIFA
RANKINGS.
I THINK THERE WILL BE, AS WE
HEAD TOWARDS THE WORLD CUP, A
NARRATIVE OF THIS QATAR TEAM
DOESN'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING,
THEY HAVE NO BUSINESS BEING IN
THE COMPETITION, THERE'S SOME
POTENTIAL MERIT FOR THAT IN
TETERMS OF THE COUNT HOSTING
THIS, BUT IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL
TEAM, THIS IS A LEGIT, TALENTED
SOCCER TEAM COACHED BY FELIX
SANCHEZ.
THEY'RE VERY DEFINED IN HOW THEY
PLAY.
THEY HAVE A CLEAR IDENTITY IN
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
THEY PLAY OUT OF THIS 5-3-2
SHAPE.
THEY HAVE A STRONG NUMBER NINE.
THEY HAVE AFIF, WHO IS THEIR
STAR.
HE IS A GENUI STANDOUT IN THE
TOURNAMENT, LIKE A JAMES
RODRIGUEZ.
HE'S NOT JAMES RODRIGUEZ, BUT
REALLY, REALLY GOOD AS THAT
NUMBER 10.
U.S. FANS MIGHT REMEMBER THAT
FROM THE GOLD CUP SEMIFINAL THEY
PLAYED AGAINST QATAR AND
THROUGHOUT T TOURNAMENT.
QATAR, I MENTIONED THEY PLAY IN
THE GOLD CUP.
THAT'S NOT A NORMAL THING FOR A
TEAM FROM THAT REGION TO BE
FLYING ACROSS TO CENTRAL
AMERICA.
T
THIS TEAM HAS DONE EVERYRYTHIN
EY CAN TO PREPARE FOR THIS
COMPETITION AND BEING CHAMPIONS
OF ASIA AS WELL.
THEY PUT IN A LOT OF PREPARATION
FROM A SPORTING STANDPOINT TO
COMPETE IN THIS WHOLE WORLD CUP.
I'M NOT SAYING THEY SHOULD BE
FAVORITES.
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF THEY
MAKE IT OUT OF A GROUP.
THIS IS A STRONG TEAM WELL
COACHED.
WELL DRILLED DEFENSIVELY.
THEY HAVE CREATIVITY.
EVEN SOME OF THE ROTATIONS,
THEY'RE A MODERN SOCCER TEAM.
YOU COULD LOOK AND SEE THEM BE
EFFECTIVE ON THE WORLD STAGE.
QATAR IS T TEAM EASIEST TO
MAKE IT PAST IN TERMS OF THE ONE
SEEDS.
I WOULDN'T BE CONCERNED IF THE
U.S. ENDED UP WITH PORTUGAL OR
ENGLAND FOR THE TSS NARRATIVE.
>> WE HAVE NETETHERLANDSOW DRAWN
PLACED INT GROUP "A."
THEY'LL BE IN THE FOURTH
POSITION IN GROUP "A."
THEY HAVE VIRGIL V VAN DIJKACK
FOR THIS TOURNAMENT.
DO YOU EXPECT THAT TO BE A
DIFFERENCEMAKER FOR THEM?
>> YEAH.
I THINK IT WILL BE.
VAN DIJK, MESSI'S EUROS LAST
SUMMER THROUGH INJURY.
U CAN SEE HE'S PROBABLY THE
BEST CENTRAL DEFENDER IN
EUROPEAN FOOTBAL RIGHT NOW.
OBVIOUSLY NETHERLANDS MISSED THE
LAST TOURNAMENT THROUGH NOT
QUALIFYING FOR THE WORLD CUP.P.
AND RONALD KOEMAN DID A GOOD JOB
OF GETTING HIM BACK ON TRACK.
HE LEFT FOR BARCELONA.
FRANK DE BOER CAME IN, HE DIDN'T
DOPPL PARARTICULARL A GOOD JOB.
THEY HAVE A GOOD TEAM, MEMPHIS
DEPAY IS A KEY PLAYER, DELICHT,
DUMFRIES.
WE SAW GLIMPSESES OF WHAT THEY
COULD DO AT THE EUROS BEFORE
SUFFERING A DEFEAT TO THE CZECH
REPUIC.
I EXPECT A GOOD SHOWING FROM THE
NETHERLANDS IN THE TOURNAMENT.
I WILL STOP NOW.
I FEEL LIKE USA MAY HAVE ENTERED
A CERTAIN GROUP.
>> THE UNITED STATES IN B3
POSITION WITH ENGLAND.
JOE, WE GEGET NENGLAND.
>> WE'RE TWO-THIRDS OF THE WAY.
>> IT'S HAPPENING.
>> WE'RE BASICALLY HALFWAY TO A
USA/ENGLAND GAME ON USA MORNING.
IT DOESN'T GET BETTER THAN THIS.
FRFROM A NARRATIVE PERSPECTIVE,
THE USA AND ENGLAND HAVE A
RIVALRY THERE EVEN IN A WORLD
CUP SENSE.
THESE ARE -- THIS IS GOING TO BE
A STRONG MATCH-UP.
I'M EXCITED SELFISHLY FOR US AS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THIS GROUP
STAGE GAME.
WE'LL HAVE RYAN REACTING TO THIS
ON DSS, I'M SURE, IN THE NEAR
FUTURE.
TAYLOR, I WANT YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
YOU HAVE MORE OF A BACKGROUND
WITH THE RIVALRY BETWEEN THE
U.S. AND ENGLAND THAN I DO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS
MATCH-UP AND WHAT DOES THIS MEAN
FOR THE U.S.?
>> THEY MUST BE DESTROYED IS THE
OBVIOUS ANSWER.
I THINK IT IS A GOOD MATCH-UP.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S ENGLAND, A STRONG
TEAM WITH A TON OF DEPTH AND
TALENT.
BUT I WILL SAY, I DO NOT FEAR
ENGLAND AS AN ATTACKING UNIT.
THE KEY TO THE EURO PERFORMANCE
S THE DEFENSIVE STABILITY, THE
MIDFIELD BASE.
IT WILL BE DIFFICULT FOR THE
UNITED STATES TO FIND A WAY
THROUGH THAT.
YOU MARK HARRY KANE, DON'T GIVE
HIM SPACE IN THE BOX, DON'T LET
HIM DIVE, IT WILL BE AN
INTERESTING MATCH-UP FOR THE
UNITED STATES.
I'M SUPER EXCITED ABOUT THAT
ONE.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT GROUP "C"
ERE WE HAVE MEXICO INTO THE
THIRD POSITION.
ARGENTINA/MEXICO.
THAT WAS A SOLID GAME IN 2002.
GRAHAM, HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
MEXICO?
>> MEXICO ARE A STRANGE ONE.
THEY FINISHED THAT CAMPAIGN
STRONGLY.
AS I SAID EARLIER, THERE'S A LOT
OF DOUBT FROM FS ABOUT THE
DIRECTION THEY'RE HEADING IN.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE INDIVIDUAL
TALENT, THEY'RE A SLIGHTLY AGING
GROUP.
YOU STILL HAVE RAUL JIMENEZ AND
MARTINO.
THAT'S THE SORT OF THING THAT
COULD GET THEM PAST THE FIFTH
GAME, WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY THE BIG
THING FOR MEXICO, THEY KEEP
TALKING ABOUT THE FIFTH GAME.
THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN PAST THE
QUARTER FINES.
THEY WANT TO MAKE THE
SEMIFINALS.
THIS MEXICO TEAM FEELS LIKE,
PARTICULARLY HAVING DROPPED INTO
THAT GROUP WITH ARGENTINA,
THAT'S A DIFFICULT ONE FOR THEM.
IT FEELS LIKE THIS MEXICO TEAM
DOESN'T STAND THE BES CHANCE OF
THROUGH PAST TOURNAMENTS, BUT
THE WORLD C CUP DOES FUNNY THIN.
>> THE WORLD CUP DRAW, WE HAD
DENMARK DRAWN INTO GROUP "D"
ALONGSIDE FRANCE AND I THINK
WE'VE GOT A GROUP OF DEATH
POTENTIAL BECAUSE IN GROUP E
JOINING SPAIN WOULD BE GERMANY.
GERMANY/SPAIN, I'M INTERESTED IN
HOW THAT WILLL GO.
IT COULD BE THE OPENER, BUT
BECAUSE IT WILL BE FIRST VERSUS
THIRD, WE'LL GET THAT MAYBE AS A
SECOND GAME.
WE GET THE INITIAL TENSION
WEARING OFF AND THEN I'M HOPING
AN EXPANSIVE, FUN GA.
>> YEAH.
TONS OF TALENT THERE.
SPAIN ARE GOING TO WANT TO TAKE
THE JOY OUT OF THAT GAME IN THE
SPANISH WAY THAT THEY OFTEN TRY
TO DO THAT.
WE SAW THIS AT THE EUROS AND IN
THE PAST.
LUIS ENRIQUE IS TRYING TO GET
THIS TEAM TO COMPLETELY DOMINATE
THE BALL.
GERMANY, THEY ARE MORE WILLING
TO PLAY IN TRANSITION.
THEY ALSO LIKE TO HAVE THEIR
FAIR SHARE OF THE BALL.
I IMAGINE THEY'LL HAVE SOME OF
IT IN THE GAME.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THIS SO
INTERESTING FOR ME.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THE TALENT ON
THE FIELD.
TONS OF MASSIVE NAMES ON BOTH
SIDES OF THIS GAME THAT WE'LL
SEE IN THE GROUP STAGE.
SPAIN WILL WANT TO DOMINATE THE
BALL AND HOW DO GERMANY RESPOND
TO THAT?
I'M ITCHING TO SEE GAMES LIKE
THIS UNFOLD AND TOO GO BACK ONE
THAT'S ANOTHER FUN ONE IN GROUP
"D."
FRANCE IS THE TEAM FROM POT ONE,
DENMARK FROM POT TWO.
YOU SAW THEM UP CLOSE WHEN THEY
WERE IN SCOTLAND'S GROUP.
THIS IS A GOOTEAM.
ERE'S THE NARRATIVE OF
CHRISTIAN ERIKSEN COMING BACK,
HEHE SCORED GOALS RECENTLY F FO
DENMARK, WHICH IS INCREDIBLE TO
SEE.
DENMARK PLAY GOOD SOER.
FRANCE MAYBE DON'T PLAY THAT,
BUT WHAT THEY LACK IN TACTICAL
EXCELLENCE, THEY MAKE UP FOR
KYLIAN MBAPPE AND KARIM BENZEMA
AN ALL THE TALENT THEY HAVE.
THAT'S ANOTHER FUN MATCH-UP.
>> AGREE ENTIRELY.
JOE, YOUR THOUGHTS ON CROATIA
DRAWING INTO A GROUP WITH
BELGIUM IN GRU GROUP "F."
URUGUAY WAS THE NEXT NATIONAL
TEAM SELECTED, THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN PLACED INTO GROUP "G," BUT
YOU CAN'T HAVE TWO COMBOBOL
TEAMS MATCHED UP.
SO THEY ARE IN GROUP "H."
>> WE TALKED ABOUT THE U.S. AND
MEXICOEING AT THE BOTTOM OF
POT TWO, I WASN'T IMPRESSED WITH
CROATIA AT THE EUROS.
THIS IS AN AGING TEAM AT THIS
POINT.
THEY'RE STILL LUKA DRICIC'S
TEAM, HE'S STILLLL A PHENOMENAL
PLAYER AS WE HAVE SEEN WITH REAL
MADRID AS THEY MADE THEIR WAY TO
THE CHAMPIONS LEAGUE, HE'S
UNREAL TO WATCH, BUT THEY DON'T
HAVE ORGANIZED STRUCTURE UNDER
DALIC.
THEY DON'T WOW ME OR IMPRESS ME
AT THE EUROS.
I DON'T KNOW THIS TEAM IS A REAL
THREAT.
FOR ME, WHOEVER IS DRAWN IN POT
THREE, WHICH WON'T BE A EUROPEAN
TEAM, IT W WILL BE A TEAM FROM Y
OTHER CONFEDERATION, YOU'RE
LICKING YOUR LIPS BECAUSE YOU
SEE CROATIA AS A TEAM THAT YOU
THEY DIDN'T LOOK INVINCIBLE IN
THE EUROS, BUT IT'S NOT THE SAME
TEAM FOR ME AT THIS POINT.
>> IT IS NOT THE SAME CROATIA
AM.
IT HAS LUKA MOMODRIC IN IT, SO
THEY MAY WIN THE WHOLE THING
BECAUSE HE TENDS TO WIN.
BRAZIL AND SWITZERLAND IN GROUP
"G."
COMMISERATIONS TO SWITZERLAND
WHO THOHT THEY WOULD AVOID
BRAZIL AND, NOPE, THE LUCK OF
THE DRAW WORKS, THEY BOUNCE INTO
GROUP G.
WE MOVE INTO POT TEE TEAMS.
I'M JUST GOING TO VAMP FOR A
MOMENT.
WE H HAD A QUESTION ABOUT WHICH
AFRICAN TEAM DID WE -- WE MOST
WANT THE UNITED STATES TO AVOID?
MY ANSWER WOULD BE SENEGAL.
THEY HAVE NOT DONE THAT YET.
BUT WE HAVE HAD THE FIRST DRAW
OUT OF POT THREE.
QATAR AND THE NETHERLANDS.H
I BELIEVE THAT WOULD PUT TWO
TEAMS FROM THE SAME
CONFEDERATION IN ONCE AGAIN.
SO WE MAY HAVE IRAN THEN
BOUNCING INTO THE USA'S GROUP.
THAT'S GOING TO BE AN
TEREING ONE.
>> GEOPOLITICS.
>> RIGHT?
OH, BOY.
>> TAYLOR, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THA FROM A
SPORTING PERSPECTIVE?
I DON'T KNOW THAT IRAN IS A TEAM
THAT A LOT OF FOLKS OUT THERE
ARE SUPER FAMILIAR WITH.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS A GOOD
DRAW?
I THINK THE FACT FOR ME, THAT
THE U.S. AVOIDED SENEGAL AND
EVEN MOROCCO MAYBE AND SOME OF
THESE OTHER TEAMS IS A BIT OF A
BOON, IS THAT THE WRONG
PERSPECTIVE?
>> I DON'T THINK IT IS.
THIS IS A STRONG IRAN TEAM,
EIGHT WINS,, ONE DRAW, THEY HAV
TALENT IN THERE AS WELL AS
ATTACK.
THEY HAVE PLAYERS FROM BRIGHTON,
PORTO, BAYER LEVERKUSEN, HE WAS
THE TOP SCORER -- THE THIRD TOP
SCORER IN QUALIFYING.
COACHED BY THE 53-YEAR-OLD
CROATIAN, TOOK OVER IN FEBRUARY
OF 2020.
MANAGED IN CROATIA IN THE MIDDLE
EAST.
HE'S A VETERAN MANAGER.
I BELIEVE THIS WILL BE HIS FIRST
WORLD CUP.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE QUITE THE
TEST AHEAD OF HIM WITH IRAN
VERSUS THE UNITED STATES AND
THEN ENGLAND IN THERE AS WELL.
I'M NERVOUS ABOUT SOME OF THOSE
HISTORICAL CONNECTIONS.
DO YOU THINK THE U.S. WILL BE
PLEASED WITH THIS ONE?
>> GENERALLY SPEAKING, YES.
BUT ACTUALLY I DID A WORLD CUP
PREVIEW OF IRANEFORE THE DRAW,
AND IRAN, AS YOU SAY THER
FINISHED TOP OF THE
CONFEDERATION.
SEEMED TO BE -- I HAVE TO SAY, A
LOT OF THE PLAYERS BESIDES SOME
OF THE OBVIOUS NAMES, I'M NOT
OVERLYLY FAMILIAR WITH, BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE THEY'RE A STRONG UNIT
ILLUSTRATED BY THAT DEFENSIVE
RECORD YOU MENTIONED.
IT MAKES ME WORRY SLIGHTLY FOR
THE U.S. THAT THEY SOMETIMES CAN
STUTTER WHEN FACING A DEFENSIVE
BLOCK.
IF THEY FACEHAT IN IRAN, THEN
MAYBE THAT IS THE SOR OF GAME
WHERE PEOPLE LOOK AT IRAN -- I
HOPE'M NOT BEING
DISRESPECTFUL, THEY'RE N A
HEAVYWEIGHT SOCCER NATION AND
PEOPLE GO THAT'SS THREE POINTS N
THE BOARD.
MAYBE IT'S NOT.
MAYBE IT'S QUITE A DIFFICULT
MATCH.
>> I'M SO EXCITED THE WORLD CUP
IS HAPPENING.
WE DID HAVE SENEGAL GET DRAWN.
THEY TOOK IRAN'S PLACE IN GROUP
"A."
IRAN INTO GROUP "B."
SENEGALITH QATAR AND THE
NETHERLANDS.
POLAND DRAWN INTO THE GROUP WITH
ARGENTINA AND MEXICO.
POLAND IN "C4 POSITION.
SENEGAL OR POLAND?ALK ABOUT
>> I'LL DOO BOTH QUICKLY.
I DON'T THINK THIS COULD BE
GOING WORSE FOR QATAR TO BE
HONEST.
THE NETHERLANDS ARE ONE OF THE
STRONGEST TEAMS IN POT 2.
YOU GO THROUGH THE NAMES, VIRGIL
VAN DIJK, FRANK DE JONG, THE
LIST GOES ON AND ON.
E NETHERLANDS ARE STACKED WITH
TALENT.
THAT'S A BRUTAL DRAW FOR THEM AS
FAR AS THE P POT TWO TEAM IN GRP
"A."
THEN THEY GET SENEGAL WHO ARE A
REALLY STRONG TEAM.
THEY BEAT EGYPT IN THEIR
PLAYOFF.
WE GOT THE LASER POINTERS AND
THAT WHOLE THING AND DISGRACEFUL
BEHAVIOR FROM THE SENEGAL FANSS
IN THAT MATCH.
IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY HAVE ON
THE FIELD, THIS IS A GOOD TEAM.
THEY MADE A GOOD SHOWING IN THE
2018 WORLD CUP.
THEY HAVE SO MUCH TALENT AS MANY
OF THESE TEAMS DO, BUT THEY HAVE
LEGITIMATE STARS, ONE IN SADIO
MANE, WHICH EVERYBODY KNOWS.
IN GROUP "C," THIS IS SHAPING UP
TO BE THE STAR-POWERED GROUP.
LIONEL MESSI AND ARGENTINA, YOU
HAVE LEWANDOWSKI AND POLAND
JOINING MEXICO.
I LIKE THIS ■GROUP FROM AN
ENTERTAINMENT PERSPECTIVE.
THIS IS SHAPING OUT TO BE QUI
GOOD.
NOT EASY FOR ANY OF THESE TEAMS
TO GET OUT OF.
>>JOE, THANK YOU FORTHAT.
WE'VE HAD AN UPDATE TO THE DRAW.
SENEGAL -- SERBIA WERE DRAWN
NEXT.
THEY CAN'T GO INTO GROUP "D" OR
"E" OR "F."
SO SERBIA JOIN BRAZIL AND
SWITZERLAND IN GROUP "G."
A SERBIAN TEAM THAT WE SHOULD
EXPECT SOME GOALS FROM?
>> YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
ATTACKING UNIT THEY ARE.
AND BEFORE NORTH MACEDONIA
UPSTAGED THEM IN QUALIFYING,
SERBIA PULLED OFF ONE OF THE
SHOCKS OF UEFAUALIFYING BY
FINISHING TOP OF THE GROUP AHEAD
OF PORTUGAL WITH A DRAMATIC
WINNER PORTUGAL, MITROVIC
SCORING IN THE 90th MINUTE TO
SEND THEM THROUGH AS THE
AUTOMATIC QUALIFIERS FROM THAT
GROUP.
THAT WAS NO FLUKE.
THEY WENT UNBEATEN THROUGH
QUALIFYING.
THAT'S A GROUP THAT INCLUDES
PORTUGAL, A POT 1 TEAM.
A LOT OF INDIVIDUAL QUALITY
THROUGH THE LIKES OF VLADDIC,
WHO WE SPOKE ABOUT.
JUVE
JUVENTUS' NUMBER NINE.
ALEKSANDER MITROVIC, A REAL
TALISMAN FOR THIS SERBIAN TEAM.
HE'S VERY, VERY USEFUL TO BRING
OF THE BENCH AND PROVIDE AN
AERIAL THAT.
TADIDIC OF AJAX, THE LAZIO CENTL
MIDFIELD, THE SEVILLA
MIDFIELDER.
LOOKING THROUGH THE SPINE OF
THTHAT TEA FROM THE ATTACK, ANDI
LIKE THAT ATTACK, THEY HAVE
TADIC FILLING A LOT OF THE SPACE
AROUND VLADDIC AND THEN THE
TWO-WAY CENTRAL MIDFIELDER.
SO THERE'S LOTS TO LIKE ABOUT
THIS SERBIAN TEAM.
I ACTUALLY THINK OF ALL THE
TEAMS IN THIS WORLD CUP DRAW,
THEY ARE ONE THAT YOU MAYBE WANT
TO AVOID.
I CERTAINLY THINK GROUP "G" WITH
SERBIA, THE QUALITY THEY HAVE,
SWITZERLAND WITH THE TOURNAMENT
EXPERIENCE AND BRAZIL, THE
TOURNAMENT FAVORITES, THAT'S
SHAPING UP TO BE A STRONG GROUP.
>> JOE, DID YOU HAVE ANYTHING
THERE?
OR SHOULD WE KEEP UPDATING ON
THE DRAW?
>> I WAS JUST G GOING T SAY,
SWITZERLAND ARE A STRONG TEAM AS
WELL.
THEY ARE MORE THAN SHAQIRI, THEY
HAVE TALENT PLAYINGNG ALL OVER
EUROPE.
THAT GROUP "G" WILL BE A TOUGH
ONE.
>> A FEW MORE UPDATES.
WHAT WE'LL DO IS KEEP LIVE
UPDATING THE DRAW AND REVISIT
THE GROUPS TO GIVED A VISIONAL
THOUGHTS.
INTO GROUP "D" WITH FRANCE AND
DENMARK, TUNISIA.
IN GROUP "E" JAPAN, SO WE HAVE
SPAIN, GERMANY AND JAPAN.
NOW WE HAVE MOROCCO INTO GROUP
"F" WAITING ON THE POSITION FOR
THEM.
IT'S BEING UNWOUND.
THE BALL HAS BEEN OPENED.
LIFTED UP.
AND WE HAVE MOROCCO IN THE THIRD
POSITION THERE.
MOROCCO ONE OF THOSE TEAMS THAT
YOU MENTIONED THAT MAYBE WILL
RELY ON INDIVIDUAL PERFORMANCES?
>> YEAH.
I THINK TO AVOID BEING OVERLY
REDUCKTIVE, OF COURSE, THEY HAVE
A HUGE STAR IWHO WILL BLITZ YOU
DOWN THE RIGHT AND THE LEFT.
THEY ARE A TEAM WHO HAS A SHOT,
NOT A POT ONE OR A POT TWO TEAM,
NOT NECESSARILY FAVORITES, BUT I
TALKED ABOUT CROATIA BEING A
FAVORABLE TEAM.
I THINKOROCCO MAY BE LICKING
THEIR LIPS HERE.
THEY EMERGED FROM THE TWO-LEGGED
PLAYOFF OF THE CONGO, LOST TO
EGYPT IN THE QUARTERFINALS.
THIS IS A YOUNG TEAM BUT THEY
ALSO HAVE VETERANS AND
TABLISHED PLAYERS.
THERS ONE I HAVE MY EYES ON,
ONE WHO REPLACED UNGERS IN
LEAGUE A.
I WANTTO MAKE A POINT TO SAY
THIS IS MORE THAN HAKIMI, BUT IT
IS ALSO HIS TEAM, SO I DON'T
THINK BELGIUM OR CROATIA WILL BE
PLEASED ABOUT HAVING MOROCCO IN
THEIR GRGROUP.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
THERE'S OTHER PLAYERS ON THE
TEAM, THEY'RE ALL VERY GOOD, BUT
AT THE SAME TIME, HAKIMI IS
PROBABLY THE BEST PLAYER.
WE FINISHED OUT POT THREE WITH
KOREA GOING INTO GROUP "H."
PORTUGAL, URUGUAY AND KOREA.
NOW WE HAVE OUR POT FOUR DRAW.
WE'VE GOT ONE INTERCONTINENENTA
PLAYOFF GOING INTO GROUP "A."
I'M NOT SURE WHICH ONE THAT IS.
WE'LL TRY TO GET SOME SPECIFICS
ON THAT.
ONE PLAYOFF TEAM IN GROUP "A."
QATAR, INTERNATIONAL PLAYOFF
TEAM..
SENEGAL AND THE NETHERLANDS INTO
GROUP "A."
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT ONE GETS
MORE TRICKY WITH THAT ONE FOR
QATAR, BUT WE WOULD ASSUME THEY
ARE MOSTLY OKAY WITH THAT DRAW
ALL THINGS CONSIDERED.
NOW WE HAVE THE FINAL TEAM IN
GROUP "B" COMING UP.
I'M VERY, VERY NERVOUS ABOUT
THIS ONE BECAUSE IT COULD BE
GHANA.
GHANA STILL A TEAM THAT COULD BE
CHOSEN.
IF WE DO GET GHANA, ENGLAND,
IRAN AND GHA ASPPONENTS
FEELS LIKE A RIDICULOUS
COMBINATION FOR THE U.S. MEN'S
NATIONAL TEAM.
I'WAITING.
THE BALL IS BEINGNG  ENED.
I'M SORT OF TERRIFIED.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE GET ECUADOR.
THE INTERNATIONAL PLAYOFF TEAM
CAN'T BE ADDED TO GROUP "A.
SO THEY MOVED TO GROUP "D" WHERE
THEY WILL JOIN FRANCE, DENMARK
ANDISIATUNISIA.
ECUADOR GOES INTO GROUP "A."
>> POOR QATAR.
MY WORD.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT GROUP
COULD HAVE GOTTEN ANY WORSE FOR
QATAR.
THAT IS -- I DON'T THINK IT'S
QUITE A GROUP OFF DEATH, MAYBE E
CAN DEBATE THAT IN A SECOND.
DEPENDS ON HOW YOU WANT TO
DEFINE THAT.
ECUADOR FINISHED FOURTH IN
QUALIFYING, WHICH IS NO SMALL
FEAT.
WE KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO
QUALIFY.
THEY FINISHED BEHIND BRAZIL,
ARGENTINA AND URUGUAY.
COACHED BY GUSTAVO ALFARO.
THAT'S A GOOD TEAM.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF STRONGNG
PLAYERS.
CHORIZO PLAYS IN THE BUNDESLIGA.
THEY SECURED A POINT AGAINST
ARGENTINA AND BRAZIL IN 2022.
THIS IS A STRONG TEAM.
TAYLOR --
>> YOUANT TO EXPLAIN WHAT'S
GOING ON?
>> THANK YOU.
SAUDI ARABIA JUST DRAWN, BUT
THEY CANNOT BE DRAWN INTO THE
GROUP WITH THE UNITED STATES.
THAT WOULD FEEL TOO RIDICULOUSLY
HISTORICALLY SIGNIFANCE.
SO THEY MOVED INTO GROUP "C"
JOINING ARGENTINA, MEXICO AND
POLAND.
A SAUDI TEAM THAT IS QUITE
STRONG.
THAT'S ANOTHER T TEAM THAT WILL
PROBABLY NOT GET A TON OF
ATTENTION HEADING INTO THE
TOURNAMENT.
THEY TOPPED THEIR GROUP IN ASIAN
QUALIFYING, SEVEN WINS, TWO
DRAWS, ONE LOSS.
LEAPFROGGED JAPAN ON THE FINAL
DAY OF QUALIFYING.
THEY ARE A TEAM COMPOSED OF SIX
CLUBS, 27 PLAYERS IN THE MOST
RECENT ROSTER COMING FROM SIX
TOTAL TEAMS.
REALLY IT'S 24 PLAYERS FROM FOUR
CLUBS.
SO YOU'RE GETTING A TON OF
THAT SQUAD. WHEN THAT TEAM AND
WE'LL GET A DIFFICULT TEAM TO
PLAY AGAINST.
A DIFFICULT TEAM TO BREAKDOWN.
THEY'LL MAKE THAT GROUP
PARTICULARLY EXCITING.
WE NOW HAVE ANOTHER PLAYOFF --
MY GOODNESS
WE MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN IT.
WE MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN IT HERE.
WE HAVE INROUP "B," I BELIEVE
IT'S POSSIBLE WE GOT SCOTLAND,
POTENTIALLY IF THEY GO.
>> THAT'S WHY I HAD MY HEAD IN
THE HANDS HERE.
THIS IS GETTING CLOSER TO
REALITY.
THE TSS GROUP OF DEATH IS
GETTING CLOSE NOW.
>> DO WE HAVE ANY CLARITY ON
WHICH OF THOSE PLAYOFFS, WHICH
TEAMS ARE THOSE SPECIFIC
PLAYOFFS?
THERE'S ONE DRAWN IN GROUP "D"
AND NOW ANOTHER IN GROUP "E."
THE GROUP "E" CAN'T BE THE
EUROPEAN PLAYOFFECAUSE T THERE'S
ALREADY TWO TEAMS IN THERE.
AM I TALKING -- YET?
>> IT'S HAPPENED.
>> I THI YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT WILL BE THE COSTA RICA GAME.
BECAUSE OF THAT POTENTIAL, THEY
GET MOVED TO GROUP "E."
THAT INTERNATIONAL PLAYOFF GAME,
THAT COULD BE COSTA RICA OR NEW
ZEALAND, THEY'RE IN GROUP "E"
ALONGSIDE SPAIN, GERMANY AND
JAPAN.
INSTEAD WE HAVE THE EUROPEAN
PLAYOFF.
IT COULD BE SCOTLAND.
SCOTLAND COULD BE IN THE GROUP
WITH ENGLAND AND THE UNITE
STATES IF THEY WIN.
IT WILL BE THE EUROPEAN PLAYOFF
IN THAT FAL GROUP.
I CANNOT BELIEVE THIS ACTUALLY
HAPPENED.
I CANNOT BELIEVE WE HAVE THAT.
GRAHAM, CAN YOU MAKE YOUR TEAM
WIN,  EASE?
>> I MEAN -- I FEEL LIKE I
SHOULDN'T BE THROWING SHADE AT
UKRAINE AT THIS GIVEN TIME, BUT
WE NEED TO WIN THAT PLAYOFF
AGAINST UKRAINE AND GET TO THE
WORLD CUP.
THAT GROUP IS JUST TOO PERFECT.
WE SAID THAT WOULD BE THE
PERFECT GROUP.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S COME OUT.
THAT WOULD BE INTERESTING.
ENGLAND, IRAN, A AND SCOTLAND
IF WE QUALIFY.
UKRAINE ANDALES COULD COME OUT
OF THAT PATHWAY AND, YEAH, THAT
WOULD STILL BE AN INTERESTING
GROUP.
>> IT COULD.
BUT COME ON -- NOBODY WANTS
THAT.
>> THAT'S NOT AN EASY DRAW.
FROM A NARRATIVE PERSPECTIVE,
IT'S GREAT.
THAT EUROPEAN TEAM, WE SAW
SCOTLAND COMPETE AT THE EUROS.
UKRAINE HAS A LOT OF TALENT.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE EASY.
GRAHAM, YOU TALKED ABOUT WAILS
WITH GARETH BALE.
THE NARRATIVE IS PHENOMENAL.
I'M NOT SURE THE U.S. GOT T
BEST DRAW I TERMS OF THEM
GETTING OUT OF THE GROUP HERE.
AGAIN, I WON'T POO-POO WHAT WE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT.
THIS IS EPIC.
>> EPIC INDEED.
WE HAVE GOT CAMEROON DRAWN.
THEY CANNOT MOVE INTO GROUP "F."
THEY WILL GET INTO GROUP "G."
SO WE HAVE BRBRAZIL, SERBIA,
SWITZERLAND AND CAMEROON.
CAMEROON COACHED BY ONE OF MY
FAVORITES, VERSONG.
I HOPE HE GETS THE RED CARD IN
THIS ONE, HE NEEDS THE RECORD,
HE IS TIED WITH ZINEDINE ZIDANE.
WE HAVE GHANA A AND CANADA YET
BE DRAWN.
GHANA IS THE NEXT NAME UP.
I BELIEVE THEY CANNOT GO INTO
GROUP "F," WHICH WOULD MEAN GANA
GOES
GHANA GOES INTO GROUP "H."
IT'S NICE TO HAVE GHANA BACK AT
A WORLD CUP.
IT'S BEEN A DOWNTURN IN FORM FOR
A GHANA TEAM THAT PLAGUED THE
UNITED STATES FOR TWO DIFFERENT
WORLD CUPS, THAT WAS FUN.
TO HAVE THEM BACK TOPPING THEIR
GROUP IN THE SECOND ROUND, THEN
DRAWING NIGERIA, GETTING THE
DRAW ON THE ROAD TO BASICALLY
WIN WITH THE DRAWOURTESY OF
AWAY GOALS, THE AYEW BROTHERS
CONTINUE TO BE A STRONG
COMPONENT FOR THIS TEAM.
AND MOHAMED CADUCE IS ANOTHERER
ONE TO KEEP AN EYE ON.
MOVED TO AJAX FOR 9 MILLION
EUROS, SUCH AN EXCITING PLAYER.
SUCH AN EXCITING TALENT.
THE AJAX CONNECTION HAS TO MAKE
YOU HAPPY.
>> OF COURSE.
I LOVE THE DIFFERENT AJAX THINGS
POPPING UP -- WE HAVE MEXICO IN
GROUP "C," BRAZIL IN GROUP "G."
LET'S GET ALL THE AJAX PLAYERS
IN THIS THING.
>> ROUNDING IT OUT, WE HAVE OUR
WORLD CUP DRAW, GROUP "F,"
BELGIUM, CANADA, MOROCCO AND
CROATIA.
THAT'S A TOUGH ONE, I THINK, FOR
CANADA.
BELGIUM WILL BE TRICKY.
MOROCCO WILL BE TRICKY.
JOE, HOW DO YOU THINK CANADIANS
ARE FEELING ABOUT THAT ONE?
>> I THINK THEY'VE GOT TO BE
FEELING PRETTY GOOD.
BELGIUM IS A STRONG TEAM.
MOTHER ROCCO WITH HAKIMI IS A
CHALLENGE THERE.
AND THE OTHER TALENT THEY HAVE.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS A BAD DRAW
R CANADA.
I DON'T THINK THEY ENDED UP WITH
THE STRONGEST AFRICAN TEAM.
THEY DIDN'T END UP WITH THE
STRONGEST POT THREE TEAM.
I DON'T THINK THEY ENDED UP WITH
A PARTICULARLY STRONG POT TWO
TEAM.
THEY HAVE A SHOT HERE, WHICH HAS
TO BE HUGELY EXCITED FOR CANADA
AFTER THEY DIDN'T DO WELL ON DAY
THREE OF CONCACAF.
>> I KNOW IT'S STRANGE TO SAY
ABOUT A TEAM RANKED NUMBER TWO
IN THE WORLD, BELGIUM FEELS LIKE
THEY'RE COMING TO THE END OF A
CYCLE.
I WAS NEVER CONVINCED BY ROBERTO
MARTINEZ AS THE NATIONAL TEAM
BOSS THERE.
THEY HAVE AOT OF AGING
PLAYERS, KEVIN DeBRUYNE AND
ROMELU LUKAKU WHO HAS THE RECORD
HERE, 68 GOALS AND 101 CAPS, NOT
BAD.
CANADA NEED TO BE WARY OF THOSE
GUYS, BUT IT WOULD BE WORSE IF
THEY GOT AZIL.
LOOKING THROUGH THE POT ONE
TEAMS, QATAR IS MAYBE THE ONLY
ONE I WOULD FANCY CANADA HAVIN
A SHOT AGAINST BELGIUM.
THAT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE THE
WASHED POT ONE TEAM EITHER.
>> LET'S RUN THROUGH IT BRIEFLY.
A FEW COMMENTS TO GET TO AS
WELL.
GROUP "A," QATAR, ECUADOR,
SENEGAL AND THE NETHERLANDS.
GROUP "B," ENGLAND, IRAN, USA
AND THE EUROPEAN PLAYOFF.
COULD BE SCOTLAND, UKRAINE OR
WALES.
COUPLE COMMEN, ENGLAND GOING
DOWN WITH THREE EXCLAMATION
POINTS.
LOS BLANCOS 23, ENGLAND, YOU
LOST ONCE, YOU'LL LOSE AGAIN.
THAT'S ALSO CORRECT.
LET'S MAKE SURE ENGLAND HAVE ROB
GREEN IN AL.
I'M NOW MESMERIZED BY J.J. ON
THE SCREEN.
GRAHAM, I WILL THROW TO YOU
WHILE I WATCH J.J.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THIS
GROUP?
I KNOW SCOTLAND AND IRAN, THE
OBVIOUS HISTORICAL CONNECTN
THERE.
>>T'S A REAL RIVALRY THAT ONE
BETWEEN SCOTLAND AND IRAN.
I SHOULD CAVEAT EVERYTHING I
SAY, WE NEED TO QUALIFY STILL.
WEWE HE TWO DIFFICULT GAMES
COMING UP.
LET'S SAY WE ARE IN THAT GROUP
HAPPY WITH THAT GROUP.REASONABLY
WE ARE SHOWED AT THE EUROS WE
CAN HANG WITH ENGLAND.
WE GOT A POINT AGAINST THEM AT
WEMBLEY.
IRAN AND THE USA WOULD BE
COMPETITIVE.
WE'RE PROBABLY THE UNDERDOGSN
THAT GROUP.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE WE'LL GET
BLOWN OFF THE PITCH BY ANY OF
GIVENHAT WARE ONE OF THE
WEAKER TEAMS AT THE TOURNAMENT,
I THINK IT'S AS GOOD A DRAW AS
WE MIGHT HAVE HOPED FOR WITHOUT
ENGLAND BEATING QATAR OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> THAT WOULD HAPPEN IF SCOTLAND
AND ENGLAND PLAY EACH OTHER IN A
WORLD CUP?
WOULD THEY HAVE TO BE -- WOULD
YOU HAVE TO ARM T BORDER
BRIEFLY?
HOW MUCH SECURURITY WOULD THERE
HAVE TO BE?
>> WE PLAYED THEM IN EURO '96,
THE EUROS LAST SUMMER.
I'M SURE -- MAYBE HISTORICALLY
AND NADA, MAYBE THE '50s AND
'60s WE DID.
CERTAINLY NOT IN MODERN HISTORY
WE'VE PLAYED THEM AT WORLD CUP.
BY WORLD CUP I MEAN '90s AND
'80s.
IT WILL BE SLIGHTLY NEW
YOU'RE RIGHT.
JUST TWO LOTS OF FOOTBALL
HOOLIGANS AT THE BORDER JOINING
THERE, FEELS LIKE SOMETHING THAT
WOULD HAPPEN ON THE DAY OF THAT
GAME.
>> SO EXCITED.
A FEW MORE COMMENTS.
IRAN CAN GET THIS AMERICAN WORK
TO.
I LIKE THE CONFIDENCE.
SOME PEOPLE TAKING TALKING ABOUT
ENGLAND.
ENGLAND FANS WAY TOO CONFIDENT
ALREADY.
MEXICO'S GROUP LOOKI TOUGH.
ANDREW, BRAZIL HAVE THE EXACT
SAME GROUP AS LAST WORLD CUP.
BRAZIL, SERBIA, SWITZERLAND AND
CAMEROON.
A BIT OF FAMILIARITY THERE.
I ASSUME YOU WOULD STILL BACK
BRAZIL TO MAKET THROUGH?
>> I WOULD.
BUT THAT GROUP, I'M SCANNING
THROUGH THE GROUPS NOW, I WANT
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THIS AS
WELL.
I'M NOTURE THERE'S A DE FACTO
GROUP OF DEATH, AS FAR AS WHICH
GROUP WE THINK IS STRONGEST,
BECAUSE THERE COULD BE A
STRONGEST GROUP WITHOUT A GROUP
OF DEATH, GROUP "G" IS NOT EASY.
BRAZIL HAVE THE MOST TALENT.
ONE OF THEOST TALENTED TEAMS
IN THIS TOURNAMENT DOMINATING
FO
FOR LARGE STRETCH OF
QUALIFYING.
SERBIA, I DID A QUICK HIT ON
THEM.
I'M HIGH ON TS SWISS TEAM.
LOTS OF NICE PLAYERS.
DENIS KARIA MOVING TO JUVE.
HE IS AN INCREDIBLE TALENT AND
SHOWOWED THAT IN THE BUNDESLIGA.
CAMEROON, IT DOESN'T GET MUCH
BETTER THAN THIS.
ON A SERIOUS NOTE, CAMEROON --
WE SAW THIS AT AFCON, THEY'RE A
LEGIT TEAM.
GROUP "G" FOR ME MIGHT BE ONE OF
THE MOST DIFFICULT GROUPS IF NOT
THE MOST DIFFICULT ONE HE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SHOUTS FOR
HARDEST GROUP OR MAYBE IF YOU
THINK THERE IS A GROUP OF DEATH?
>> I DON'T THINK THERE'S A GROUP
OF DEATH.
"G," POSSIBLY THE STROEST.
BUT "H" AS WELL WITH PORTUGAL,
URUGUAY, KEA AND I'M MISSING
ONE.
WHO IS THE OTHER TEAM IN GROUP
H?
GHANA.
I FEEL LIKE THAT'S A PRETTY
COMPETITIVE GROUP.
URUGUAY THERE.
WE HAVE NOT SPOKEN ABO THEM.
THEY HAVE TRANSITIONED INTO A
NEW GENERATION, REALLY, REALLY
EFFECTIVELY.
THEY HAD LUIS SUAREZ AND EDINSON
CAVANI ERA, THAT FOLLOWED FROM
PLERS LIKE DIEGO FORLAN.
THIS IS A COUNTRY OF JUST 4
PRODUCING PEOPLE LIKE DARREN, R
RODRIGO BETANCOURT, URUGUAY
TEAMS ARE ALWAYS ASSOCIATED WITH
DEFENSIVE STABILITY AND BEING
GOOD IN THE AIR, IN PTICULAR
WITH GAUDIN.
RONALD ARAJO IS VERY VERSATILE.
HE'S BEEN PLAYING RIGHT BACK FOR
BARCELONA.
PEOPLE WILL BE DRAWN TO NAMES
LIKE LUIS SUAREZ.
BUT ACTUALLY WHEN YOU DIG DOWN
AND LOOK AT THAT NEW GENERATION,
THEY'RE STRONG AS WELL.
THEM LANDING IN THAT GROUP MAKES
THAT GROUP VERY STRONG, VERY
FORMIDABLE.
>> IS IT A STRANGE THING WHEN WE
LOOK AT THESE GROUPS TO KNOW FOR
SURE WHAT THE- THE STRONGEST,
THE MIDDLE, THE WEAKEST WOULD BE
BECAUSE WE HAVE THESE PLAYOFFS
THAT STILL HAVE TO HAPPEN.
PERU MAKES GROUP "D"
FASCINATING.
PERU COULD BE TRICKY, IT COULD
BE AUSTRALIA AS WELL, SO NOT
KNOWING WHO EXACTLY IT WILL BE
MAKES IT HARD TO KNOW THE EXACT
STRENGTH.
THE CONSENSUS OPINION SEEMS TO
BE THAT FRANCE GOT A FAIRLY EASY
DRAW.
MY GENERAL FEELING IS THAT NO
DRAW IS PARTICULARLY EASY WHEN
IT COMES TO THEORLD CUP
BECAUSE FRFRANCE, WE KNOW, HAVE
TONS OF TALENT.
PERU HAVE PROVEN THEY CAN BE A
TRICKY TEAM.
THAT'S A PERU TEAM THAT
HISTORICALLY OR IN PAST
COMPETITIONS HAVE NOT HAD THEIR
FULL STRENGTH LINEUP.
THEY COULD SPRING A SURPRISE.
DENMARK HAVE THE TALENT, ABILITY
SOMETHING HAPPEN.ABLE TO MAKE
TUN
TUNISIA, ONE OF THOSE TEAMS THAT
WILL BE -- MAYBE IGNORED OR NOT
GIVEN THE ATTENTION THEY
DESERVE.
BUT IT'S A VERY GOOD TUNISIA
TEAM.
IT'S ANOTHER ONE WHERE THEY
BASICALLY BREEZED THROUGH
QUALIFYING IN THE SENSE THAT
THEY GOT FOUR WINS, ONE DRAW,
ONE LOSS IN THEIR GROUP STAGE
GAMES.
THEY GET PAST MALI WINNING THE
FIRST LEG 1-0 ON THE ROAD.
TWO GOALS CONCEDED THROUGHOUT
QUALIFYING.
IT WILL BE A STRONG DEFENSIVE
UNIT.
MADE IT TO THE QUARTERFINALS OF
AFCON, LOST TO ALGERIA IN THE
2021 ARAB CUP.
NOT A TON OF HOUSEHOLD NAMES ON
THE SQUAD.
THE ONE THAT PEOPLE MIGHT COME
TO KNOWHAHN HANIBAL MESRI.
THEY'RE COACH ED BY COUDREY WHO
COACHED 26 DIFFERENT TEAMS SINCE
HE STARTED MANAGING HOW LONG
AG
HE'S GOT TO HAVE STARTED INHE
EARLY '90s, MID '90s TO HAVE
THAT MANY CLUBS IN?
>> I BELIEVE HE STARTED COACHING
IN 2002.
HE'S BEEN RUNNING A BIT.
>> IN AND OUT, BABY.
>> HE'S MAKG MOVES, CAUDREY.
>> FRANK DE BOER.
>> I LIKE THAT ONE.
SO, I THINK -- UNLESS -- DO YOU
ALL DISAGREE?
I'M SAYING THERE'S NOT ONE
OBVIOUSLYY WEAK TEAM.
IS THERE A CANDIDATE FOR EITHER
OF YOU?
JOE, DO YOU HAVE ONE?
>> NOT YET.
NOTHING I FEEL OVERLY CONFIDENT
ABOUT BEFORE WE DIVE IN AND DO
OUR REARCH.
WE'LL HAVE A TON OF WORLD CUP
CONTENT OUT.
AS THE WORLD CUP GETS CLOSER,
WE'LL HAVE MORE RESEARCH ON EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF THESE TEAMS.
I DON'T WANT TO HEDGE MY BETS
YET.
YOU WOULD BE FOOLISH TO COUNT
ANY TEAM OUT IN THE TOURNAMENT.
THESE ARE ALL CAPABLE TEAMS.
TOURNAMENT SOCCER IS A VELLER,
IT'S AN EQUALIZER.
IT TURNSAD TEAMS INTO CAPABLE
TEAMS AND GREAT TEAMS INTO
MEDIOCRE TEAMS.
THAT'S MY O NOTE.
THE TEAM I WILL MENTION, WE
TALKED ABOUT GROUP "H,"
PORTUGAL, GHANA, URUGUAY, SOUTH
KOREA.
GHANA IS NOT AS STRONG AS
THEY'VE BEEN.
THEY SNEAKED PAST NIGERIA,
THAT'S AN IMPRESSIVE WIN TO MAKE
IT INTO THE COMPETITION, BUT
THEY WERE BOSSED IN THOSE GAMES
BY NIGERIA.
IT'S EXTREMELY UNFORTUNATE FOR
NIGERIA THA THEY'RE NOT HERE.
GHANA IS NOT REALLY A TEAM THAT
I'M EXPECTING TO GIVE PORGAL
AND URUGUAY THAT MUCH TROUBLE,
MAYBE NOT EVEN SOUTH KOREA
EITHER.
BUT AGAIN, I WILL HEDGE MY BETS
HERE AND NOT SAY MUCH MORE
BECAUSE I COULD END UP LOOKING
FOOLISH LATER ON.
>> I THINK THAT'S WISE.
GRAHAM, YOU WANT TO GO THE SAME
ROUTE?
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING YOU WANT TO
SPOTLIGHT BEING WEAKER THAN
OTHERS?
>> AH.
SIMILAR TO JOE, I DON'T WANT TO
PUT ALL MY MONEY ON AERTAIN
TEAM BEING WEAKER THAN THE REST
BEFORE WE'VE DONE OUR RESEARCH.
THE TOURNAMENT STARTS IN
VEER.
>> WE HAVE TO WAIT EIGHT MONTHS.
WHATEVER IT IS.
>> SO THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
THINGS THAT CAN CHANGE.
I'M NOT SURE WHICH PATH IT IS,
BUT ONE OF THE INTERCONTINENTAL
QUALIFICATION SPOTS AS
AUSTRALIA, UAE AND PERU.
I THINK THOSE THREE TEAMS,
AUSTRALIA WHO HAVE TRADITIONALLY
BEEN A HEAVYWEIGHT OF -- NOT
TRADITIONALLY BECAUSE THEY MOVED
INTO AFC, THEY HAD A REAY POOR
QUALIFICATION CAMPAIGN.
THEY ARE STRUGGLING WITH A BIT
OF A TALEN PROBLEM.
THERE'S QUESTIONS OVER THE
COACHING LEADERSHIP OF THAT
TEAM.
THEY STILL HAVE TO GET THROUGH
E INTERCONTINENTAL PLAYOFF.
UAE, THEY NOT QUALIFIED FOR
WORLD CUP SINCE 1990.
THEY ACHIEVED SOME SUCCESS AT
THE ASIAN CUP.
WE'RE LKING SEMIFINALS, THIRD
PLACE FINISHES AT THE ASIAN CUP.
NOT A HUGE AMOUNT OF PEDIGREE
THERE.
PERU, MAY POTENTIALLY THE
STRONGEST.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE PERU.
THE COLOR THEY BROUGHT TO THE
2018 WORLD CUP WAS FANTASTIC.
IT WAS ONE OF THE E LIGHTS OF
T
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE TOURNAMENT AND
MAYBE THEY HAVE SLIGHTLY MORE
EXPERIENCE THAN THE OTHER TWO.
YEAH.
THAT INTERCONTINENTAL PATHWAY,
MAYBE SLIGHTLY WEAKER THAN THE
REST FOR ME.
>> FEW MORE COMMENTS FOR US TO
GET TO.
DON'T COUNT OUT JAPAN, JOE AND
AHAM HAVE DONE THAT.
WE WILL NOT COUNT OUT JAPAN.
JAPAN STILL IN THE WORLD CUP A
INVOLVED.
POLAND IS TOUGH.
GROUP KRR"C" IS LOOKING NICE.
I'M GOING TO SAY EARLY CONTENDER
FOR TOP SPOT IN THAT ONE WOULD
BE ARGENTINA.
CONTROVERSIAL TAKE, I KNOW, BUT
IT FEELS LIKE IT COULD BE OPEN
FOR THAT SECOND PLACECE SPOT.
WEWEWE K TEAMS THAT ARE ALWAYS
EXPECTED TO GO FAR COULD CRASH
OUT OF THE GROUP STAGE.
WHAT WE SHOULD PREDICT IS SAUDI
ARABIA AND POLAND TO MAKE IT OUT
OF GROUP "C."
JOE, THAT WORK FOR YOU?
>> YEAH, YOU READ MY MIND.
REAL.THERLANDS ARE SCARY FOR
NO ARGUMENT THERE.
DREW SAYS JOE LOWERY ALWAYS
BRINGING THE FIRE TAKES.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
I ALSO APPRECIATE SOMEONE ASKING
WHY DRAKE BELL WAS ON THE
SCREEN.
I'M SURE THAT WAS FOR JOE.
I ALSO DON'T REALLY KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT DRAKE BELL TO KNOW WHO
THEY MIGHT HAVE BEEN
SPECIFICALLY REFERRING TO.
GRAHAM, DOES THAT NAME MEAN
ANYTNG TO YOU?
>> COULD HAVE BEEN LITTLE RYAN
BABAILEY?
>> I LIKE HIS --
>> YOU G THE GOLD FOIL IN.
GRAHAM, HOW IS RYAN FEELING
BEFORE WE CALL IT A DAY?
HOW IS HE FEELING ABOUT THIS
DRAW?
IS HE AS SMUG AS I PRESUME?
>> YES.
JUST SMUG NOISES COMING OUT OF
THAT FACE, AS USUAL.
YEAH.
HOLD ON, HE'S SAYING WHY DO WE
EVEN NEED TO PLAY THE
TOURNAMENT.
JUST GIVE ENGLAND THE TROPHY
ALREADY.
>> I FEEL LIKE YOU SPENT TOO
MUCH TE WITH HIM.
THAT DOES SOUND LIKE A THING
THAT RYAN BAILEY MIGHT ACTUALLY
SAY.
ON THAT NOTE, THANK YOU TO
EVERYBODY WHO JOINED US FOR "THE
WORLD CUPUP DRAW."
IT WAS A BIT CHAOTIC AT TIMES.
I'M S EXCITED FOR ENGLAND,
IRAN, USA AND POTENTIALLY,
HOPEFULLY, MAYBE SCOTLAND.
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ONE GENTLEMAN, GRAHAM, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
BREAK DOWN THE DRAW WITH ME.
>> THANK YOU.
TAYLOR ROCKWELL, THAT HAS MADE
ME PRETTY EXCITED.
THE DRAW IS WHEN YOU CAN START
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
TOURNAMENT.
IT WILL BE UPON US BORE WE
KNOW IT.
>> I'M SO EXCITED.
JOE LOWERY, THE OUTSIDER, THE
BAD BOY, THANK YOU AS WELL.
>> YEAH, TAYLOR, THANK YOU.
YOU KILLED IT.
HOSTING THE SHOW IS NOT EASY TO
DO.
YOU KILLED IT.
I'M WITH GRAHAM.
I'M UNBELIEVABLY EXCITED FOR
THIS TOURNAMENT.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LONG SIX,
SEVEN, EIGHT MONTHS BEFORE THIS
THING GETS HERE.
>> WE HAVE MORE SHOWS, LIVE
SHOWS O ON THE B/R APP.
WE'LL BE DOING THE CHAMPIONS
LEAGUE SEMIFINALS PREVIEW AND
THEN POST GAMEHOWS THE FINAL
AS WELL.
I THINK I SPEAK FOR EVERYONE
WHEN I SAY WRE EXCITED TO DO
THAT.
WE HOPE THE VIEWERERS, LISTENER
JOIN US FOR THOSE.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE, AGAIN,
FOR LISTENING, WATCNG, FOR
STICKING WITH US AS WE NAVIGATED
THE GROUPS.
WORLD CUP COMING UP.
I CANNONOT WAIT.
WE'LL BE BACK SOON.
♪